l'objectif est d'unir par la prière tous
les membres de la communauté adventiste
ainsi que ses sympathisants autour d'une
même cause pour qu'ensemble nous
demandions à dieu d'intervenir de
soutenir et d'apporter sa paix à tous
ceux et celles qui sont touchés par le
virus covit 19 à tous ceux et celles qui
doivent lutter pour trouver une solution
tous ceux et celles qui doivent prendre
des décisions importantes pour les
nations et les peuples les politiques
les médecins le personnel soignant les
pompiers toutes ces personnes qui sont
sur le pied de guerre
24 heures sur 24 notre monde vit une
situation inédite et nous ne sommes pas
en marge
ici en martinique la peur gagne les
états les royés les coeurs au fur et à
mesure que le virus se répand
nous croyons qu ensemble unis avec tous
ceux qui veulent nous rejoindre dans
cette chaîne de prière que dieu
interviendra selon son plan bienveillant